unless you're basically living under a
rock the Internet is just swooning over
Pedro he's the star of The Last of Us he
was just on SNL he's actually had a very
long career and a lot of like his fellow
actors are posting pictures of like here
was me acting with him in the 90s he's
been here all along and Pedro has no
idea what's going on and says please
everyone can we just focus on Harry
Styles end quote
um I gotta say Pedro the humility is
making you hotter stop it
our start I get wanting to focus on
Harry Styles but I can multitask Paige
okay I can do it and I will say is there
anything hotter than someone who doesn't
know that they're hot you know what I
mean I I don't think so does anyone else
think so because the minute someone does
think they're all that in a bag of chips
I'm like no I don't now you've lost me
you don't need my love you have too much
of your own